leur proposer avec champagne jus
d'orange et comme on appelle un cocktail
à base de champagne et du orange
oui on me mazars aux lèvres une forme un
coeur là c'est très joli et nous on se
revoit quand dans une autre vie
[Musique]
salut ritom sévit damien fait pas venir
prendre un café rôle à arette ne tombe
pas cooking damien s'est réjoui qu'un
pépin je me suis réveillé un beau matin
dans une société adhérente
je suis dans un univers parallèle où les
fameux 10 est ce que je devais faire ça
va c'est pas fini non non non non
marchand ce cas pas de monde
monte à grand chose pour que tout les
projets voient le jour
bonjour vous savez qu'on appelle à un
cocktail à base de champagne et du gange
mimosas c'est quoi
je demande si t'as pas un problème en
normal c'est un petit complément lasse
plus possible
à temps
l'habitude fait tout pour débarrasser
des must mais elle
ge est une troupe c'est que disparaisse
imaginez un monde où ce sont les femmes
qui se font belles pour moi c'est moi
qui leur fait des compliments
quelle horreur
quoi tu as raison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]